alors que l'épidémie de kovy de 19 sévit
depuis bientôt un an
en france une partie des victimes
indirectes reste largement oublier les
étudiants devant la situation très
préoccupante qu'ils vivent
quotidiennement et l'absence de réaction
suffisante du gouvernement nous avons
souhaité mettre à l'ordre du jour nous
voulons alerter proposer des mesures
rapides et concrètes face à la montée de
la précarité et des risques
psychosociaux épuisante notre jeunesse
cela fait plusieurs semaines que les
témoignages affluent les étudiants
veulent se faire entendre
il sait ends nous disent combien leur
situation est dégradée
matériellement et plus inquiétant encore
mentalement
la crise sanitaire a fait ressortir
l'état de délabrement déjà présents des
universités la question est posée
que pouvons nous proposer à nos jeunes
pour améliorer leurs conditions de vie
et d'étude particulièrement dans le
contexte sanitaire actuelle mais aussi à
plus long terme
quelles perspectives voulons offrir
notre jeunesse
les chiffes publiés ces derniers mois
sont effrayants selon un sondage de la
fondation abbé pierre d'un pour cent des
jeunes ont eu recours à l'aide
alimentaire lors de la crise sanitaire
la moitié des étudiants rapportent des
difficultés à payer leurs repas et leur
loyer la précarité étudiante ne fait que
se renforcer depuis des années face à un
coût des études qui augmente et en
logements très cher qui représente en
moyenne 70% des buses et alors que 136 8
% d'étudiants ont touché des bourses en
2019 2020
celle ci le permettent souvent pas de
vivre sans travailler à côté et le cumul
entre et tuent les emplois est la
première cause d'échec à l'université à
cette précarité grandissante s'ajoute le
poids de l'isolément devant les écrans
qui mène un enseignement désincarné sans
contact humain où il peine à suivre le
rythme a conservé dans motivation pour
beaucoup c'est la même journée qui se
répète comme en témoigne marc vap
étudiante à toulouse réveil 7h30 ou 8h
d'écran par jour
repas révision dodo au début on se dit
que ça va aller
et puis on finit par craquer selon une
étude réalisée sur 70 mille étudiants
lors du poignet confinement 43 % des
étudiants
sont affectés par un trouble de santé
mentale comme l'anxiété ou la dépression
face à cela les services de santé
universitaire sont totalement saturés
tout cela engendre un manque de
perspective pour les étudiants des
risques de décrochage ou ne pas valider
son année les inquiète mais aussi les
stages annulé
l'entrée sera massue du travail tendue
ou l'impossibilité de partir étudier à
l'étranger
un âge où on en prend l'habitude de son
envol
de nombreux étudiants sont rentrés chez
eux chez leurs parents pour les
enseignants cette situation est
également très difficile
comment donner des cours interactifs
face à une mosaïque d'écrans noirs
comment intéresser les étudiants qui
n'ont parfois jamais rencontrés dont il
devine les difficultés sans pour autant
avoir les moyens de les identifier et de
les aider le personnel administratif est
lui aussi obligés de faire et défaire
depuis des mois pour organiser les
emplois du temps en distance yale puis
en présentiel tout en respectant les
directives changeantes imprécises et pas
forcément réalise pas forcément adapté
aux réalités de terrain et il faut
avouer que le décalage entre les
protocoles sanitaires interpelle les
commerces et les écoles sont restés
ouverts
les étudiants en classes préparatoires
et bt a suivi les cours normalement il y
a une différence de traitement évidente
et l'étudiant à l'université se sentent
à juste titre laissés pour compte les
mesures sociales d'urgence arrive au
coup par coup
quelques centaines d'euros par étudiant
selon leur profil avec un interlocuteur
différent à chaque fois
le caf le crous pôle emploi etc la mise
en place du ticket du restaurant
universitaire à 1 euro pour tous est une
très bonne chose mais je me suis
inquiété sur sa mise en oeuvre
l'autre lors de votre venue madame la
ministre le lundi 1er février à
l'université de bordeaux
seuls dix restaurants universitaires
étaient au vert sur 27
il était impossible de prendre des repas
sur place sous la pluie les étudiants se
regrouper dans des voitures alors que la
surface du restaurant universitaire
permettait de mieux respecter des gestes
barrières
là aussi des ordonnances venu d'en haut
était aveugle à la réalité
du très terrain qui est un des risques
sanitaires supplémentaires qui doivent
être évités il ya la suite de votre
annonce de vendredi qu'a permis la
restauration sur place je suis soulagé
mais encore une fois ceux ci auraient pu
être envisagées plus tôt d'autres
mesures sont positives bien sûr avec la
création de jobs étudiants le
recrutement d'assistantes sociales et de
professionnels de santé universitaire et
le chèque santé mentale même si la
démarche pour en bénéficier et compliqué
à l'université de bordeaux montaigne
c'est une infirmière pour dix-huit mille
étudiants et une salle embauche d'un
poste de psychologue
on est loin du doublement annoncées pour
la totalité des collectifs et syndicats
étudiants que nous avons rencontré ces
mesures sont loin d'être suffisantes car
l'aco vide aggraver une situation qui
était déjà très critique en termes de
pauvreté des étudiants des chèques à
l'université de manque de moyens
généralisée à quand une réponse
structurelle à ce problème qui donnerait
à tous les étudiants les meilleures
conditions pour réussir leurs études
dans les pays scandinaves
chaque étudiant perçoit une allocation
individuel indépendamment du revenu de
ses parents pour lui permettre de se
consacrer sereinement à ces études et de
prendre son autonomie
alors oui une telle mesure a un coût
comparable à celui du cce où la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation
mais ce n'est pas tant un coup de caunes
investissements dans la réussite des
jeunes
un investissement aussi pour casser le
déterminisme social
cette plaie qui minent notre société
française au système solaire scolaire
inégalitaire avec l'allocation
d'autonomie on reconnaît des étudiants
comme des adultes à part entière et
c'est aussi un autre rapport qui se noue
entre les tailles ces jeunes fondé sur
la confiance
madame la ministre nous vous demandons
solennellement d'entamer une vraie
réflexion sur ce sujet désireux de
s'inscrire dans une démarche
constructive et durable avec le groupe
écologiste solidarité territoire nous
avons écrit un courrier au premier
ministre qui vous a été également
transmis madame la ministre
dans celui ci nous appelons
un grand plan massif d'investissement
dans les universités pour soutenir la
jeunesse sur le court et le long terme
autour des grands axes suivants
l'égalité de traitement de tous les
étudiants qui soit en classe
préparatoire aux grandes écoles
un bts ou à l'université le retour en
cour des étudiants à 50% avec des moyens
humains et techniques pour permettre le
dédoublement des groupes des cours
hybride cours présentiels diffusé aussi
redit ce temps ciel en faisant confiance
à la communauté universitaire pour
organiser au mieux en fonction des
contraintes et possibilités du contexte
une sécurité financière accrue avec une
aide d'urgence pour tous les étudiants
ainsi qu'une revalorisation
significative des bourses et des apl des
investissements sanitaire massive dans
les locaux universitaires en matière de
ventilation et d'équipements numériques
l'intelligent de tous les étudiants avec
une adaptation des examens la situation
sanitaire et l'assurance qu'aucun
étudiant ne sera pénalisé en raison de
l'épidémie une politique de recrutement
sanitaire ambitieuse pour garantir un
nombre suffisant d'assistante sociale et
de professionnels de santé auprès des
étudiants car pour le moment le compte
n'y est pop une politique de recrutement
donc sanitaire michel joly dit une
politique de santé mentale d'urgence
avec un remboursement sans avance de
frais des consultations de psychologie
de ville et sur le plus long terme la
création d'une allocation d'autonomie
pour tous les étudiants
madame la ministre nous connaissons les
efforts financiers conséquents que le
gouvernement a fait depuis le début de
la crise mais aujourd'hui nous vous
demandons de continuer ses efforts en
point envers notre jeunesse et d'entente
réellement leur cri d'alarmé
ces mesures que nous appelons de nos
voeux ne sont pas des dépenses est il
utile mais et des investissements
nécessaires investissons dans notre
avenir
investissons dans notre jeunesse je vous
remercie
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues avant la crise
sanitaire la précarité étudiante était
déjà une réalité
près d'un étudiant sur deux travaillé
pour financer ses études et subvenir à
ses besoins
l'accès au logement aux soins à une
alimentation saine relever d'un défi au
quotidien pour bon nombre de nos
étudiants
l'action gouvernementale reposait alors
sur trois leviers complémentaires
l'augmentation des bourses sur critères
sociaux la construction de nouveaux
logements universitaires
la mobilisation des aides pour les
situations d'urgence depuis le 14 mars
2020 la décision gouvernementale de
fermer les établissements d'enseignement
supérieur pour protéger la population du
coc vite 19 a changé la donne depuis les
situations de précarité que nous
connaissions avant la crise s'aggrave et
se multiplient la moitié de nos
étudiants qui travaillait pour vivre ont
perdu leur emploi
à cela s'ajoute la détresse
psychologique liée à l' isolement social
d'une grande partie de notre jeunesse
l'étude menée à ce sujet par
l'observatoire national de la vie
étudiante en dit long puisque 31 % des
étudiants interrogés au connu une
détresse psychologique lors du
confinement s'ajoutent encore les
incertitudes qui pèsent sur l'avenir des
futurs diplômés
l'accès aux stages dans un tel contexte
de crise sanitaire et économique est
fortement menacée la constitution des
futurs réseaux professionnels des tout
autant nous connaissons des risques
accrus de décrochage scolaire notamment
en première année de licence
tout n'est pas perdu l'apprentissage a
connu un engouement inédit
l'an passé malgré la crise avec la
signature de cinq cent mille contrats le
plan de soutien à l'apprentissage du
gouvernement il y est pour beaucoup
nous sommes très favorables aux
indépendants à la prorogation de ce
dispositif
comme l'indiqué notre ministre du
travail lisa bête bornes les mesures
palliatives prises par le gouvernement
sont des gestes plus ou moins importants
les repas 1 euro pour tôt pour tous
pardon
l'accès au soutien psychologique et
surtout le retour progressif au cours en
présentiel et c'est bien là madame la
ministre
le vrai sujet les étudiants demandent à
étudier dans de bonnes conditions à
retrouver le lien avec leurs universités
leur professeur leur camarade
l'émulation qui se trouve au sein des
campus et irremplaçable je partage à cet
égard la vie du professeur delfraissy le
retour en cour des étudiants est une
question de santé publique
nous devons aussi veiller à la bonne
lisibilité de l'action publique et pour
cela assurer une cohérence entre les
différentes décisions comment beaucoup
de mes collègues l'ont dit justifier la
fermeture des universités par prudence
alors que les classes prépas et les
classes de bts reste ouverte
les étudiants demandent que leur avenir
ne soit pas sacrifiée ils demandent
surtout à être écouté et pris en
considération
fin janvier le président de la
république annoncé une reprise partielle
des cours en présentiel
nous devons favoriser la souplesse des
dispositifs de nombreux étudiants ne
pourront pas revenir étudier en
présentiel un jour par semaine
faute de logements faisons confiance aux
jeunes qui sont l'avenir de notre pays
ne les infantilise ont pas
ne condamnons pas leur avenir des
milliers de jeunes enfants actuellement
sont regroupés en classe de maternelle
en école élémentaire partagent la même
table de restauration sans masque de
jeunes adultes qui peuplent des campus
universitaires et de grandes écoles sont
je pense capable d'être responsable de
respecter des gestes-barrières si le
risque n'est pas dans les amphithéâtres
où les étudiants seront masqués et
distanciée pourquoi ne pas limiter
l'accès des restaurants universitaires
ont repas à emporter
ce sont des centaines de milliers de
jeunes qui baissent les bras et risquent
d'abandonner leurs études
nous devons trouver des solutions à
court terme et à long terme pour
faciliter la résilience de la jeunesse
et éviter qu'elles ne payent sous une
autre forme
un lourd tribut à l'épidémie n'oublions
pas elle est la richesse de la france de
demain je vous remercie monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues samedi je participais à
bagneux une collecte alimentaire au
profit des étudiants de cette commune
populaire de mon département des
personnes aux revenus très modestes
donné ce qu'elle pouvait ému par les
images de ces longues files d'étudiants
attendant une pitance devenu leur seul
repas quotidiens la solidarité est
souvent exercée par les pauvres pour les
plus pauvres que je garde en mémoire
l'image de cette femme au panier de
courses à peine rempli offrant un paquet
de pâtes et me demandant comment il
était possible que dans notre pays une
personne qui accèdent à l'université
puisse souffrir de la faim je n'oublie
pas qu'en novembre 2019 par la loi de
finances rectificatif votre gouvernement
à tous primés 35 millions d'euros de
crédits du programme vie étudiante en
2018 et 2019 ce sont 100 millions
d'euros de crédits votés par le
parlement qui n'ont finalement pas été
affecté à la vie étudiante
par votre gouvernement l'an passé à
l'occasion de la discussion des quatre
loi de finances rectificative
j'ai proposé des amendements pour
apporter aux universités au centre
national des oeuvres universitaires et
scolaires des moyens d'urgence pour leur
permettent d'aider rapidement les
étudiants par la voix de monsieur
darmanin alors ministre de l'action des
comptes publics le gouvernement m'avait
expliqué qu'il n'y avait pas besoin de
crédits budgétaires supplémentaires
la politique du quoi qu'il en coûte à
ignorer les campus et la détresse
estudiantine cet automne nous avons
discuté d'une loi de programmation de la
recherche que le gouvernement nous a
présenté comme le plus gros effort
budgétaire depuis la libération
l'université n'a bénéficié dans ce cadre
d'aucune aide budgétaire supplémentaire
comme si les étudiants d'aujourd'hui ne
serait pas les chercheurs de demain
j'entends aujourd'hui les déclarations
compassionnel du gouvernement qui
s'alarment du mal vivre des étudiants
mais la pandémie n'est pas n'en est pas
l'unique cause dans les universités
comme à l'hôpital
la crise sanitaire et la révélatrices
d'une situation de sous investissement
chronique qui a fragilisé tout le
service public de l'enseignement
supérieur certes cet état de carences de
l'université n'est pas imputable à votre
sol gouvernement cela fait une vingtaine
d'années que l'état n'investit plus dans
l'enseignement supérieur depuis 20 ans
l'université est soumise aux ciseaux
malthusien d'une hausse continue du
nombre d'étudiants et d'une stagnation
de ses budgets
ainsi le budget moyen alloué à chaque
étudiant ne cesse de baisser depuis dix
ans cette année il devrait passer sous
le seuil symbolique des dix mille euros
en revanche le budget moyen consacré aux
étudiants des classes préparatoires n'a
cessé d'augmenter
il sera bientôt de 16000 euros par
capita voilà votre choix politiques
cela fera bientôt quatre ans que votre
gouvernement gère avec tous les pouvoirs
les affaires de notre pays
l'heure est donc venue des bilans dans
le domaine de l'enseignement supérieur
la politique menée par votre ministère
ne se distingue en rien de celle menée
par tous ceux qui vous ont succédé elle
n'a fait qu'accompagner un progressisme
et irrépressible des engagements de
l'état
l'université n'a pas été une prière une
priorité politique de votre gouvernement
les premières victimes de ce sous
investissement chronique sont les
étudiants avant la crise leur situation
matérielle d'existence ne leur
permettait pas de poursuivre leur cursus
dans de bonnes conditions pédagogiques
avec la crise il souffre d'une
paupérisation dramatique qui s'ajoute à
l' isolement
la privation de vie sociale l'absence de
toute perspective est une inquiétude
grandissante sur la valeur qui sera
attribuée à leur diplôme avant la crise
40 % des étudiants travailler pour se
payer leurs études
avec la crise près de 60 % d'entre eux
ont été privés de toute activité
salariale le président de la république
nous a expliqué je le cite qu'un
étudiant devait avoir les mêmes droits
qu'un salarié alors pourquoi ne
profitent ils pas des mesures de chômage
partiel pour toutes ces activités
salariées qui les faisait vivre et
qu'ils ne peuvent plus exercer les
étudiants non plus n'en peuvent plus de
souffrir de la faim de la réclusion du
sentiment d'abandon de la privation de
tout ce qui faisait le bonheur d'être
jeune et plus encore de cette impression
terrible que votre gouvernement n'a pas
de projet d'avenir pour eux j'emprunte
ma conclusion un étudiant qui livrait
son désespoir au journal la croix
je le cite je lis tous les matins la
vraie honte
la vraie honte c'est de voir tant d du
d'étudiants peinant à se nourrir alors
qu en se formant il crée la richesse de
demain
jean merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre chers collègues concertation
stabilité et cohérence voilà ce que
souhaitent les étudiants et la
communauté enseignante voilà ce dont a
besoin l'université les efforts
consentis par nos étudiants en cette
période de crise sanitaire sont immenses
ne connaissant ont finalement que peu de
formes graves de lakovic 19 ils sont
soumis à des restrictions drastiques de
leurs modes de vie entraînant pour
beaucoup une grande précarité
d'innombrables témoignages illustrent
cette détresse étudiante à cela s'ajoute
l'incertitude face à l'avenir notre
jeunesse considérée comme inébranlable
montre aujourd'hui les stigmates d'un
combat qu'elle ne peut supporter à elle
seule les récentes annonces du président
de la république même si elles prennent
en compte une partie des revendications
ne peuvent être considérées comme
suffisantes
ces mesures d'accompagnement ont été
mises en oeuvre en réaction à la crise
étudiante et c'est ce manque
d'anticipation qui plonge dans le
désarroi des milliers de jeunes
rappelons l'action dynamique et concrète
des collectivités je le constate
notamment dans mon territoire région sud
département des alpes-maritimes commune
mobiliser de toutes leurs forces pour le
bien
des étudiantes la métropole nice côte
d'azur présente en ce moment même de
nouvelles actions le village de gilles
est quant à lui organise une collecte
pour leur venir en aide
sur le terrain je dialogue régulièrement
avec des étudiants et membres de la
communauté enseignante
ces échanges m'ont amené alerter
rapidement le gouvernement puis à
proposer la demande de reprise à hauteur
de 50 % ainsi que l'accélération et la
systématisation de l'offre de
vaccination pour les volontaires
l'université passant au tout par des
interactions entre professeurs et
étudiants couper ce lien c'est donc
amoindrir cette envie que les étudiants
de se lever tous les jours pour
apprendre rétablir un rythme de travail
à 50% que les cours à distance ont
tendance à diluer permettra de sortir
les étudiants de l' isolement et d'une
solitude ou s'érode
jour après jour leur motivation limitée
à 20% le présentiel ne permet pas de
résoudre toutes les inégalités il faut
poursuivre les efforts étudiant en prépa
bts et à l'université ont les mêmes
droits mais de mais bénéficient pas des
mêmes conditions garanties par l'état
et c'est notamment cette différence de
traitement qui suscite l'incompréhension
en quoi ce brassage finalement serait
différent je crois qu'il faut cesser
cette infantilisation qui sacrifie cette
génération dorénavant il ne s'agit plus
seulement de corriger les erreurs du
passé mais de ne pas les répéter cette
pandémie nous oblige à repenser
l'université dans son ensemble et dans
toute sa complexité
la crise a certes est mise à nu des
failles structurelles mais elle ne va
pas créer en ce sens saisissons cette
opportunité pour les combler l'urgence
est absolu et nous devons investir sur
le long terme il faut à mon sens
renforcer le principe d'autonomie des
universités chaque composante présente
une spécificité
je pense par exemple à la filière staps
ses particularités ne permettent pas
aujourd'hui une application uniforme des
mesures dédiées par votre ministère il
ya un vrai besoin de flexibilité il faut
de la cohérence de la clarté et un cap
ce ne sont pas mes mots madame la
ministre mais ceux du chef de l'état
deuxième enjeu donc celui des incessants
de variation réglementaire pour ne plus
courir de manière erratique après la
crise il faut cesser cette valse
délétère de circulaires et présenter une
stratégie de long terme
il n'est plus possible qu'étudiants et
enseignants mais pour seul
et un live l'inconstance cette exigence
est rendu encore plus urgente par la
menace d'un confinement
il faut aussi admettre que la formation
des étudiants en ressort dégradé il est
donc impératif d'y remédier pour cela il
faut non seulement préparer dès à
présent la rentrée prochaine mais aussi
réfléchir à un plan de restructuration
de l'enseignement supérieur pour
terminer l'effet de masse lie aux très
bons résultats obtenus en licence
réinterroge les modalités de sélection à
l'entrée en master des pistes de
réflexion existe les universitaires les
tiennent à votre disposition
la crise sanitaire possède le mérite de
faire vaciller des certitudes établies
de questionner les discours dominants et
de rappeler les décideurs alors devoir
d'humilité
elle a aussi vu une remarquable
mobilisation des établissements
d'enseignement supérieur et de recherche
pour assurer au pied levé dans des
conditions difficiles la continuité de
leur mission académique la france
gagnerait à réconcilier avec à se
réconcilier avec les acteurs de ces
territoires
en abandonnant ses tentation récurrente
de concentration afin d'accepter de
promouvoir une différenciation
connaissance et reconnaissance vont de
pair c'est l'un des principaux défis des
temps qui s'ouvre le chantier est
immense
tout cela réclame ce qui a tant manqué
jusqu'à présent de l'anticipation de la
cohérence et des moyens à hauteur de
l'enjeu
c'est le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues le malaise
grandissant des étudiants affectés par
la crise qu'ovide inquiète leur
précarité augmente massivement et
accentue des situations déjà très
fragile
les effets délétères de la situation l
anxiété et qu'elle génère montre des
conséquences graves sur leur santé
mentale des jeunes accrue par l'
isolement et les cours à distance des
compensations stress dépression idées de
suicide
les signaux de détresse et de
souffrances psychologiques sont
multiples même si les statistiques
disponibles sont globalement
insuffisantes les difficultés
économiques sont provoqués en
particulier par l'arrêt de l'ombre aux
jobs étudiants près de six sur dix ont
réduit ou arrêté leur activité rémunérée
en rendant leur location entraînant à
six l'arrêt de leur étude des demandes
aide alimentaire concerne massivement
ceux ci à leur présence à ce jour près
de 30 % de l'augmentation certaine image
du fils d'attentes pour l'egypte
choquée l'aggravation de la situation
s'observe également au sentiment d'une
forme d'abandon et de l'inutilité
s'estimant saint suffisamment écoutés et
sollicité par les pouvoirs publics
ils voient leur horizon s'obscurcir sans
constater une réaction qui soient leurs
yeux à la hauteur des enjeux et de leur
peur pour l'avenir
ces détériorations été prise en compte
que tardivement et de façon insuffisante
malgré de nombreuses alertes et je me
sur chaque jour la difficulté de la
tâche du gouvernement en cette période
exceptionnelle mais nous devons tous
ensemble être beaucoup plus exigeantes
en faveur du monde étudiant il faut de
toute urgence madame la ministre tant
que des mesures d'éradication du virus
ne seront pas applicables adapter la
stratégie du pays à tous les secteurs
d'activité n'abandonner personne la vie
sociale des jeunes étudiants est
essentiel des dernières annonces bien
que tardive du gouvernement vont dans le
bon sens mais manque d'ampleur un jour
par semaine en présentiel avec une jauge
maximale de 20 % de repas par jour 1
euro un accompagnement psychologique
forme de chèque pour ceux qui sont en
mal être
en tout cas la décision toute récente
leur permettant de manger dans les
espaces crous avec un protocole
sanitaire renforcée va dans le bon sens
et accompagne utilisant leur retour très
partiel je tiens à vous remercier pour
votre engagement décisif en ce sens
madame la ministre je néglige pas
d'autres aides décidées depuis début de
la crise avec les sorties parfois en
décalage avec les ressentis de terrains
élevés qu en tord et les étudiants j'ai
eu copie de la lettre de la présidente
diversité de franche comté et de
bourgogne signés par d'autres présidents
de composantes en ce sens qui nous parle
de cet immense désespoir des étudiants
avec une interrogation la
différenciation de traitement entre les
étudiants et ceux qui sont assez gpcg pe
les bts pour la scolarité est maintenue
la question résonne elle la pause à si
la jeunesse universitaire était moins
précieuse que celle qui étudie dans les
lycées il nous faut donc des priorités
donner priorité aux échelons locaux de
proximité les plus aptes à prendre en
compte les difficultés sociales des
étudiants
mon département et ville ont un rôle
plus important à jouer il faut leur
garantir jude budgétairement les
conditions d'une prise en charge
optimale pour tous aujourd'hui c'est une
dimension territoriale de celui d'harry
tu es dans la proximité nous nous avons
besoin les incompréhensions entre l'état
les territoires doivent être levés en
faveur de donner priorité un calendrier
de reprise des cours en présentiel en
liaison avec une campagne volontariste
de tester vaccination rien ne l'interdît
à ce stade malgré les incertitudes sur
l'évolution de la pandémie
ces générations est précieuse il faut
que la vaccination soit effective pour
tous les étudiants étudiantes
cela apportera la preuve de leur
importance donner priorité à l'action
des collectivités locales pour accepter
la mise en place des dispositifs
d'emploi de formation de stage adopté à
la période donner priorité à chaque
université dans sa singularité et son
autonomie pour trouver des solutions
appropriées à ses propres difficultés
l'institution elle même à ses propres
difficultés
mais elle épuisée par les changements et
enfin donner priorité à la réflexion sur
l'ensemble des dix positive écrit deere
days de bourses et de revenus étudiants
de façon sérieuse sans excès idéologique
mais sans tabou nous sommes pour une
prise en compte améliorer des inégalités
constatées ou vécu ce ciel comme
territoriales chaque étudiant doit
pouvoir vivre dignement pendant ses
études et non de ses études
les comparaisons internationales doivent
nourrir utilement nos réflexions et
affection je vous massive être aussi
merci chers collègues
après toutes ces interventions la parole
est désormais à madame frédéric vidal
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur de
la recherche et de l'innovation
ce président est monsieur le président
mesdames et sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs
je tenais tout d'abord à vous remercier
d'avoir organisé ce débat et je suis
très heureuse que le sujet des étudiants
et de leur avenir intéresse la haute
assemblée en ce début de février 2021
s'est prise en compte de ces difficultés
pour ma part elle a eu lieu et vous le
savez parce que nombre d'entre vous ont
pu m'accompagner sur de nombreuses
visites sur le terrain dès le 1er
confinement dès le 1er confinement les
étudiants comme les enseignants au sein
des universités ont alertés ont dit que
nous devions préparer cette rentrée
universitaire et je tiens à remercier
l'ensemble des personnels parce que
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait durant tout
l'été et je crois que nous pouvons
collectivement leur rendre hommage
alors oui à un âge où l'on rêve de tous
les possibles à un âge où l'on entre
dans l'enseignement supérieur
c'est très difficile que l'avenir se
résume finalement à un écran il ya un
besoin immense un besoin immense de
retrouver du lien social un besoin
immense de retrouver du lien humain pour
les étudiants entre eux avec leurs
camarades mais aussi avec leur
professeur et pour les professeurs parce
qu'il est extrêmement difficile
d'enseigner sans avoir le regard des
étudiants qui questionne alors la
question elle a été posée je vous le
disais
dès la sortie du premier confinement
avec une incertitude qui ne vous aura
pas échappé sur les conditions
sanitaires et les établissements ont
travaillé sur plusieurs scénarii ils ont
travaillé sur une reprise en présentiel
que nous souhaitions tous et qui a pu se
faire pour quelques semaines
malheureusement et puis une reprise en
2012 lorsque les cas de kloster ont
commencé à apparaître dans les
établissements mais aussi lorsque un
certain nombre de responsables
politiques ont qualifié la situation
dans les facultés de catastrophique et
ont cru bon à ce moment là de dire que
la jeunesse était facteur de
transmission de ce virus j'ai toujours
défendu le fait que les établissements
d'enseignement supérieur n'était pas des
lieux où l'on se contaminer lorsque l'on
suivait ses enseignements
mais ça va me permettre de répondre à
l'une de vos premières interrogations je
pense que vous avez tous un jour ou
l'autre fréquenté un campus
universitaire si c'est le cas j'imagine
que vous vous rappeler à quel point la
vie sur un campus est différente de la
vie dans un lycée alors oui certains
étudiants en études supérieures parce
qu'ils étaient dans des conditions
d'études au sein d'un lycée ont pu
continuer à bénéficier de cours en
présentiel au mois avec des jauges à 50%
et j'allais dire c'est déjà ça et puis
dans les établissements et bien des
photos des réseaux sociaux des balances
la fac ont fait que petit à petit l'idée
s'est installée que les facultés étaient
des lieux de contamination et les
recommandations des spécialistes des
conseils divers et variés ont estimé
qu'il était essentiel de fermer les
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
c'était le début du second confinement
et la réaction porté par le gouvernement
a été de refuser la fermeture des
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
alors effectivement il avait peu
d'étudiants
mais croyez moi pour ceux qui ont pu
continuer à aller dans les bibliothèques
universitaires pour ceux qui ont pu
continuer à bénéficier des salles de
ressources avec l'accès aux ordinateurs
avec l'accès au réseau et bien été
content que les universités ne soit pas
entièrement fermée puis pour toutes les
disciplines qui avait des travaux
pratiques pour toutes les écoles dans
lesquelles il était essentiel de
maintenir des enseignements en
présentiel et bien ils ont pu être
maintenus alors oui c'était très peu
d'étudiants entre 7 et 8% qui
fréquentaient les établissements mais
néanmois vraiment la volonté des
établissements a été de ne pas fermer et
dès le mois de novembre nous avons
commencé à travailler des protocoles
sanitaires et ses protocoles sanitaires
il devait être capable de s'adapter à
tout y compris à la remontée du taux de
contamination y compris à l'apparition
de variants et c'est pour ça que c'était
long et c'est pour ça que c'était
compliqué parce que vous l'avez dit vous
avez été plusieurs à le dire il n'y
avait rien de pire que d'annoncer puis
de changer d'avis puis de recommencer
c'était ce dont les établissements ne
voulait pas et c'est avec les
établissements que nous avons mis en
place des protocoles pour trois étapes
trois étapes dès le début du mois de
janvier
première étape faire revenir les
étudiants les plus fragiles et croyez
moi les enseignants étaient capables de
voir à quel point pour des étudiants
internationaux pour des étudiants
ultramarins pour des étudiants qui
vivaient extrêmement difficilement le
confinement et les cours à distance
il était essentiel de les faire revenir
par petits groupes et de les faire
rencontrer d'autres étudiants
d'où l'importance et le rôle des tuteurs
et puis les premières années parce que
ses premières années justement comme il
n'avait passé que quelques
jours ou quelques semaines au sein des
écoles et des universités bien il
n'avait pas eu le temps de se faire des
camarades pour certains d'entre eux ils
venaient d'autres régions ils venaient
d'autres pays et ce besoin de créer des
liens qui ensuite pouvait être maintenu
au travers des réseaux sociaux et bien
ils s'expriment et majoritairement pour
ce que l'on appelle les primo entrants
et puis la troisième étape le troisième
protocole c'était être en capacité de
faire revenir tous les étudiants quel
que soit leur niveau sur les campus et
ça c'est ce à quoi nous sommes arrivés à
partir du lundi 8 février et donc tous
ces protocoles ont été préparés et co
construit avec les établissements alors
oui c'est compliqué oui c'est difficile
de refaire des emplois du temps et
croyez-moi l'immense majorité des
personnels l'immense majorité du corps
enseignant et bien et prêt à faire des
choses complexes et compliqué pour faire
revenir les étudiants parce que les
étudiants font comme pour moi à la fois
leur boussole et leurs priorités
ce travail très important qui a été mené
avec l'ensemble des établissements il
est compliqué encore et je crois que
c'est important de le dire par la
complexité des envies il y a dans les
établissements des personnels qui estime
que c'est dangereux de venir travailler
et qui préfère rester en télétravail il
y as au sein des étudiants des étudiants
qui sont retournés dans leur lieu
familial dans leur lieu d'habitation
familiale et qu'ils n'ont pas envie de
revenir il ya ceux qui ont des
difficultés pour revenir parce qu'ils
ont laissé leur appartement ils existent
il ya aussi ceux qui finalement se
trouve très bien et veulent continuer à
étudier à distance et c'est un défi de
plus pour les établissements peut être
capable d'identifier ces étudiants mais
ce que je voudrais partager avec vous ce
soir à ce sujet
c'est j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le dire
le taux de présence aux examens le taux
de présence aux examens est resté le
même que celui du premier semestre de
l'année 2019 2020 et ça signifie que le
système universitaire et le système des
écoles a tenu ça signifie que les
enseignants les enseignants chercheurs
ont été chercher les étudiants ça veut
dire que les tuteurs ont joué leur rôle
ça veut dire que tout le système s'est
mobilisée au service des étudiants alors
tout n'est pas parfait tout ne
fonctionne pas mais en tout cas je
voulais saluer à la fois ce travail des
personnels des établissements et aussi
ce travail des étudiants pour les
étudiants parce que vous en avez parlé
et bien sûr j'y reviendrai il a de
nombreux étudiants qui sont en
souffrance
il a aussi de nombreux étudiants qui ont
dépassé ses souffrances et qui ne
demande qu'à faire ne demande qu'à aider
ne demandent qu'à participer
et cela aussi bien sûr nous devons être
capables de le saluer un petit mot
monsieur le sénateur ingré sur la
question des vaccins
la question des vaccins vous savez bien
que pour le moment la seule chose dont
nous sommes sûrs c'est qu'il protège
individuellement et ça a été rappelé
forte heureusement individuellement les
jeunes lorsqu'ils sont contaminés
développe très rarement des formes
graves
nous ne savons pas aujourd'hui si les
vaccins protègent de la transmission et
de la contamination vers les autres donc
vacciner les jeunes aujourd'hui et
l'ensemble des scientifiques sont
d'accord sur ce point au moins sur celui
là eh bien nous n'avons aucune idée de
l'efficacité de ce dispositif les
difficultés économiques des étudiants ça
a été rappelé par plusieurs d'entre vous
et je vous en remercie elle ne date pas
d'hier
effectivement mais elles ont été
amplifiées par cette crise où
effectivement les étudiants ont perdu ce
qu'on appelle les petits jobs les jobs
étudiants tous les étudiants qui avaient
des contrats de travail ont été
évidemment pris en charge comme toute
personne ayant un contrat de travail
tous les étudiants qui avaient des
contrats d'apprentissage ont bien
entendu étaient accompagnés et aidés et
si nous avons maintenu le nombre
d'apprentis cette année c'est parce que
le gouvernement a été présent auprès des
entreprises pour faire en sorte que
l'apprentissage ne soit pas sacrifiée
s'ils avaient des contrats de
professionnalisation ils ont pu les
conserver mais effectivement pour tous
ces petits jobs ces petits emplois qui
aident à la fin du mois eh bien nous
avions une véritable difficulté que la
crise sanitaire a amplifié que la
difficulté économique des familles à
amplifier que la difficulté à avoir des
échanges certains étudiants
internationaux ne sont pas rentrés chez
eux cet été parce qu'ils avaient peur de
ne pas pouvoir revenir parce qu'on ne
connaissait pas les conditions
sanitaires et la façon dont pourrait se
faire leur retour
eh bien oui tous ces étudiants là sont
en difficulté mais là encore nous
n'avons pas attendu pour agir
c'est dès le mois de juin que les loyers
des résidences universitaires ont été
gelés dès le mois de juin que l'on a
annoncé qu'il n'y aurait pas
d'augmentation des frais d'inscription
dès le mois de juin aussi que nous avons
pour la deuxième année consécutive
augmenter les bourses sur critères
sociaux
et puis nous avons pu doubler les fonds
d'être d'urgence et je voudrais rester
un moment sur ces fondettes d'urgence
leur particularité c'est qu'il peuvent
être demandés par tout étudiant un
étudiant boursier comme un étudiant
non-boursier un étudiant international
comme un excision nationale la
particularité c'est que nous avons
fortement augmenté ses fonds d'être
d'urgence et qu'un étudiant qui
pouvaient percevoir jusqu'à un peu plus
de 3000 euros
aujourd'hui percevoir jusqu'à un peu
plus de 5000 euros par an la réalité
c'est que nous avons simple
les processus et les directeurs de crous
peuvent directement attribués 500 euros
d aides d'urgence sans avoir sans que
les dossiers et à être examiné en amont
de l'attribution de ces aides
c'est tout cela qui a été fait et c'est
de cela aussi que les étudiants ont
besoin
et puis une aide ponctuelle pour
accompagner tous les étudiants boursiers
au mois de décembre plus de 550 mille
étudiants sur les deux millions sept que
compte notre pays sont aujourd'hui des
étudiants boursiers et puis nous allons
évidemment continué et continue et ça
signifie quoi ça signifie nous
préoccuper de la question des stages et
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le sénateur
grosperrin ça ne se fait pas seul ça ne
se fait pas d'un bureau rue descartes ne
se fait pas de paris nous avons besoin
de stage sur le terrain ça se fait donc
avec la même avec l'adf avec la rfa avec
la cgpme avec l'ensemble des
organisations patronales et des
organisations syndicales
ça se fait en interministériel avec ma
collègue elisabeth bornes et nous sommes
en train de recenser sur le territoire
les stages nous sommes en train d'en
créer dans les administrations parce que
oui certains diplômes nécessite qu'il y
ait des stages disponibles pour les
étudiants et c'est notre prochain défi
est notre prochain challenge
et puis pour pallier à la perte des
petits jobs
eh bien oui nous avons créé des emplois
des emplois étudiants dans les crous les
emplois étudiants dans les universités
et lors de la visite à bordeaux qui a
été mentionnée par deux d'entre vous
mesdames les sénatrices vous avez
et raconter ce que nous avons vus
ensemble dans ses services de santé
universitaire le rôle très important de
ces étudiants sentinelles ce sont des
emplois étudiants des universités le
retrait important des étudiants
référents dans les cités universitaires
qui repèrent ceux qui vont mal c'est
aussi des emplois que nous avons créé le
rôle essentiel des étudiants tuteurs qui
reprennent en petits groupes avec une
dizaine d'étudiants toujours les mêmes
les fondamentaux et les bases qui ont eu
du mal à être acquises pendant le
premier semestre
c'est tout cela qui sur le terrain
permet à nos étudiants d'être accompagné
et finalement de leur donner aussi la
possibilité au travers de ces emplois
vient de pallier à l'absence de jobs
étudiants
et puis c'est aussi la modification de
la règle des services civiques alors oui
ça n'est pas parfait oui on pourrait
faire plus oui on pourrait faire mieux
mais nous sommes en train d'y travailler
il faut simplifier drastiquement la
question de l'emploi étudiant une action
forte aussi en faveur de l'aide
alimentaire ça a été rappelé par
plusieurs d'entre vous et je vous en
remercie
là aussi fallait mettre en place des
protocoles sanitaires nous sommes dans
une situation nous avons généralisé le
couvre-feu nous sommes dans une
situation où certains d'entre vous
réclament un nouveau confinement en
disant que nous prenons des risques et
dans le même temps on fait revenir les
étudiants à l'université
dans le même temps prend en compte le
fait que vous avez raison quand ils
partent avec leur sac mais qu'ils ont
cours cinq minutes après ça veut dire
qu'il mange quand il mange plus tard
après leurs cours
nous l'avons vu vous avez raison nous
l'avons vu lundi vendredi il y avait des
protocoles pour être assis dans les
restaurants universitaires
c'est aussi en allant sur le terrain
c'est là que l'on voit la réalité des
actions qui sont faites c'est là qu'on
voit le dernier kilomètre c'est là qu'on
voit que effectivement si on n'a pas
suffisamment de protocoles robuste pour
convaincre les autorités sanitaires eh
bien on n'est pas allé jusqu'au bout de
ce que l'on voulait porter est ce que
l'on voulait par tct des repas un euro
équilibré pour tous les étudiants
est ce qu'on voulait porter c
évidemment la capacité pour de les
consommer alors vous mentionner les
restaurants universitaires qui était
fermé oui bien sûr puisqu'il n'avait
très peu d'étudiants sur les campus
beaucoup de restaurants universitaires
étaient fermés il y en a plus d'une
centaine qui ont réouvert en dix jours
parce que ré ouvrir un restaurant
universitaire mettre en place ces
protocoles sanitaires
c'est pas quelque chose qui se fait d'un
claquement de doigts je crois que vous
le savez aussi les structures de
restauration vous l'avez vu aussi elle
s'adapte et vous avez entendu les
directeurs de resto u qui nous disait si
les étudiants n'ont pas cours demain eh
bien ils peuvent partir avec des repas
supplémentaires si on est fermée le
week-end eh bien ils peuvent évidemment
remporter suffisamment de repas et puis
arrêtons d'opposer ce que fait le réseau
des oeuvres qui est absolument essentiel
avec ce que font les associations qui
pour certaines sont des associations
étudiantes et qui là aussi pratiquer la
solidarité l'engagement le bénévolat
pour venir en aide aux autres étudiants
bien sûr que ces associations étudiantes
nous les subventionnant pour créer des
épiceries solidaires qui sont bien plus
que des épiceries qui sont aussi des
lieux où l'on vient chercher du lien
social où l'on vient chercher des
conseils et puis toutes les initiatives
qui nous permettent de faire en sorte
que les étudiants puissent et bien être
accompagné dans ces moments difficiles
pourquoi voulez-vous les opposer c'est
essentiel que nous puissions travailler
tous ensemble et là aussi je prendrai
l'exemple de la région bretagne comme
tendant le premier confinement la région
bretagne a confié au crous des
financements pour augmenter les aides
alimentaires pour augmenter le soutien
psychologique pour augmenter
l'accompagnement financier des étudiants
qui en avaient besoin c'est comme cela
qu'on avance on avance tous ensemble
parce que c'est la jeunesse de notre
pays commun un mot enfin sur la question
de l'accompagnement psychologique des
étudiants
nous avons mis en place
différentes mesures sur le front de
l'accompagnement humain mais vous l'avez
dit vous avez raison
la première des réponses c'était de
faire revenir les étudiants s'étaient de
leur permettre de recréer du lien social
et vous avez raison de souligner aussi
l'immense responsabilité des étudiants
bien sûr qu'ils sont conscients que nous
sommes en train de leur permettre de
revenir alors que nous avons une
inconnue nouvelle inconnue trois
nouveaux inconnus des variants et que
oui
nous observons au jour le jour ce qui se
passe mais regardez ce qui se passe
partout en europe partout dans le monde
c'est quelqu'un est capable aujourd'hui
de faire une modélisation réaliste et de
dire après demain on sera capable de
faire ci ou dans une semaine on sera
capable de faire ça da qu'ils produisent
cette modélisation réaliste oui nous
sommes dans l'incertitude oui
incertitudes génère du stress où il
c'est vrai pour l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens
et oui c'est encore plus vrai à un âge
où on a besoin de construire ses
certitudes à un âge où l'on se construit
soi même c'est pour ça qu'il était
essentiel de pouvoir faire de
l'accompagnement et du suivi des
étudiants fragile
les tuteurs les étudiants référent les
étudiants sentinelle c'est de
l'accompagnement des pères par les
perses et ce qui fonctionne le mieux les
étudiants ont du mal à dire qu'ils vont
mal à d'autres personnes qu à leurs
camarades et ça c'est une réalité et ça
sur le terrain tout le monde vous le
dira aussi cette mise en oeuvre elle
nécessite que pour chaque demande nous
ayons une réponse appropriée
et puis vous étiez à bordeaux dont vous
avez entendu aussi cette psychologue
dire il ne faut pas tout médicalisé les
étudiants ils vont pas bien parce qu'ils
ont besoin de voir d'autres étudiants et
pour certains d'entre eux le fait de
voir d'autres étudiants ce sera
suffisant et puis le protocole de
parcours de soins de santé psychologique
et vous avez raison il faut travailler
la prévention mais là pour le moment on
est dans la réponse immédiate ce
parcours de soins il a été fait avec des
professionnels de santé il a été fait
avec la fédération de psychologues
il a été fait
dans penser dans un parcours de soins un
médecin généraliste que ce soit un
médecin de service de santé
universitaire où que ce soit un médecin
qui a accepté de pratiquer le tiers
payant tant que l'étudiant nepad avance
à faire un psychologue que ce soit un
psychologue du service de santé
universitaire du bureau des chicots
logique des crous des villes
tout le monde est mobilisé et là encore
on peut faire appel à des psychologues
internes aux établissements ou à des
psychologues de ville je croix madame la
sénatrice que vous disiez vous aviez
beaucoup discuté avec l'université dans
votre très beau département des
alpes-maritimes
eh bien figurez vous que dans cette
université dans ce très beau département
des alpes maritimes que je connais un
tout petit peu eh bien lorsque l'on
permet aux services de la ville qui ont
mis en place des aides psychologiques
pour les jeunes et pour les étudiants au
service universitaire aube a pu au crous
au chu de travailler ensemble
on arrive à 20 psychologues mobilisés
sur le terrain 20 psychologues pour une
université qui fait trente mille
étudiants
nous y sommes à un psychologue pour 1500
donc vous voyez que les choses sont
possibles à partir du moment où on le
fait au service de nos étudiants et où
on le fait sans arrière pensée
politicienne
pourquoi trois séances de psychologues
rembourser ou plutôt trois séances de
psychologues pour lesquelles les
étudiants n'ont aucuns frais parce que
c'est ce que nous ont dit les
spécialistes où les choses se règlent en
3 séances où on a besoin d'un parcours
de soins plus long donc les choses sont
simples il y a trois séances qui sont
prises en charge et au bout des trois
séances soit l'étudiant va mieux soit
l'étudiant a besoin de continuer dans le
parcours de soin et bien sûr et continue
dans ce parcours de soins sans avoir d'
avance de frais à faire c'était tout
l'idée de construire le parcours de
soins dès le départ et c'est comme ça
qu'on est capable d'accompagner les
étudiants qui le nécessitent
vers des soins qui peuvent relever de la
psychiatrie
plus seulement de la psychologie et là
encore vous avez raison vous avez répété
en permanence le mot confiance mais je
ne fais que ça je fais confiance aux
établissements parce que je sais à quel
point ils ont à coeur aussi la santé
psychologique des étudiants et je fais
confiance aux maires des villes
universitaires et je fais confiance à
l'ensemble des professionnels de santé
parce que tous veulent le bien être des
étudiants
parce que les étudiants c'est
effectivement et ça a été dit le bien
commun de la nation
je ne peux pas je ne peux pas conclure
sans répondre à un certain nombre
d'inexactitudes que j'ai pu entendre le
coût des études qui relève de la
responsabilité de l'état du gouvernement
du ministère a baissé depuis 2010 est je
pense que personne n'a oublié la
suppression de la cotisation de sécurité
sociale je pense que personne n'a oublié
le doublement pour la deuxième année
consécutive des bourses sur critères
sociaux je pense que personne n'a oublié
différentes mesures qui ont pu être
prises par ce gouvernement
monsieur ouzoulias ce jeu vous c'est
profondément honnête
alors quand vous dites que healy à 35
millions d'annulation du budget vie
étudiante
vous savez bien que c'est un budget de
guichet et donc s'il avait fallu
rajouter comme l'avons fait cette année
plusieurs dizaines de millions d'euros à
ce programme nous l'aurions fait et s'il
n'y a pas besoin d'en rajouter parce que
comme je l'avais dit il y a un nom
recours aux aides parce que trop
complexe parce que trop compliqué et
c'est pour ça qu'on a simplifié
alors effectivement il ya des
annulations de crédits mais croyez-moi
ce programme est un programme qui sera
toujours abondé du nécessaire et je
crois que j'en ai fait la preuve sur ces
quatre dernières années
ce programme a été abondé dans les
différents projets de loi de finances
rectificatif ce programme est abondée
autant que de besoin une fois de plus
c'est un programme de guichet oui il y
avait un sous investissement massif dans
l'université le plan l'étudiant a permis
de réinvestir 1
hier d'euros simplement pour le premier
cycle universitaire je ne dis pas que
c'est parfait
jeudi en tout cas que si on n'avait pas
injecter ce milliard d'euros alors oui
il y aurait un problème encore plus
grand au sein des universités
on a parlé de l'entretien des bâtiments
universitaires depuis combien de temps
est ce qu on dit qu'il faut les
entretenir ses 1,3 milliard d'euros qui
sont débloqués pour que d'ici la fin
il y ait plusieurs milliers de bâtiments
universitaires de restaurant
universitaire de résidences
universitaires qu'ils soient remis aux
normes
et au passage ça fera du bien à la
question de l'écologie
voilà pour conclure je voudrais vous
dire que évidemment vous l'avez compris
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui dans le
monde universitaire et ce qui se passe
avec les étudiants c'est ma
préoccupation de tous les jours est ce
que je voudrais vous demander aussi
c'est de faire très attention très
attention s'il vous plaît aux mots que
vous employez non cette génération n'est
pas une génération sacrifiée si nous
leur disons ça eh bien alors nous allons
les démoraliser plus encore non
n'ajoutons pas encore des difficultés
ces étudiants ne les traitons pas de
morts vivants c'est terrible
faisons leur confiance et dont ceux qui
en ont besoin restons ensemble pour
aider tous ceux qui en ont besoin et
surtout surtout reconnaissons à quel
point nous avons besoin que notre
jeunesse garde de confiance et pour que
notre jeunesse garde confiance
il faut aussi que nous ayons confiance
dans le système d'enseignement supérieur
qui forment notre jeunesse je vous
remercie
[Musique]